here's every version of Kane the
Conqueror explained Nathaniel Richards
is the name he has when he was born in
the 30th century and decided to travel
back to ancient Egypt in order to
conquer all of reality Rama Tut is the
name Nathaniel tuck when conquering
ancient Egypt but was defeated by The
Fantastic Four and forced to return to
the 30th Century Scarlet Centurion is
the name Nathanael took while he was
traveling back to the 30th Century but
stopped in the modern era he made a suit
similar to Dr Dooms and then gave
himself the name Scarlet Centurion but
he was defeated by The Avengers and
forced to flee Kane the Conqueror is the
name that Nathaniel took when he
returned to the 30th Century but
overshot his timeline and ended up in
the 31st century and then conquered the
world iron lad is the result of Kane
traveling back and trying to convince
his teenage self to become a villain
ultimately iron land refuses and he
becomes a superhero instead and immortus
is the name that Nathaniel gives himself
later on in life when he gives up
Conquering the universe and travels to
limbo in order to monitor the time
stream make sure you follow for more